el Jurado de cannes completó el maratón
de 21 películas con Las dos últimas
cintas de la competencia
[Música]
la directora italiana Alice joshuacher
presentó la comedia dramática la quimera
la historia de un hombre que sale de la
cárcel en el camino de regreso a su
pueblo atraviesa una extraña serie de
Aventuras la cinta cuenta con la
actuación del británico George o'connor
el inolvidable príncipe Carlos en la
serie de Crown la quimera es una cinta
con despliegue de apuestas visuales
cámaras aceleradas actuaciones
desbordantes que dan un toque de
extravagancia a esta historia y en el
medio un par de historias de amor y un
romance perdido que da el título a esta
película
el respetado director británico Ken
louch cerró la competencia con theol Ok
fiel a su Estilo comprometido y directo
que en louge concibió un drama con
trasfondo de crisis social y racismo Dj
valentine es el propietario del único
pub que queda en el pueblo y que se
sostiene A duras penas gracias a algunos
clientes asiduos la situación se torna
aún más tensa cuando el pueblo recibe a
un grupo de refugiados sirios que son
rechazados violentamente
el veterano que en loucha ha ganado dos
veces la palma de oro en cannes a sus 86
años sigue expresando a través de sus
películas la falta de solidaridad y el
racismo reinante esta vez pone su foco
en el conflicto sin fin que se Libra en
Siria y que ha empujado a miles de
personas Al exilio forzado que en launch
recibió ayer en cannes una larga ovación
e hizo un llamado a la compasión con
aquellos que los estragos de la guerra